hey everybody dr sammy here your
friendly neighborhood entomologist and
today
we're going to talk about photosynthesis
there's very little life on this planet
that could exist without photosynthesis
it is the prerequisite for pretty much
everything you see around you it's how
you get from the intangible light of the
sun
to physical bodies like those of humans
or hungry hungry caterpillars
but what does photosynthesis actually
mean
i hear people say all the time the
photosynthesis is the process by which
plants
make sugar
from light
and it almost seems like magic
light is not a substance it is not made
up of the molecular building blocks that
compose all matter and thus it doesn't
have mass you can fill a room with light
and never run out of space
so how could you possibly make something
physical out of it
well
you can't
so
instead light is a form of energy energy
being the capacity to do work
so this is where it's helpful to know
word origin the word photosynthesis is
made up of two greek words it literally
means light and to put together
that's right in addition to being an
entomologist i dabble a little bit in
etymology just to make sure i'm
maximally confusing to people
anyway you're literally using light to
drive reactions that combine ingredients
into new products a form of work so
you're not turning light itself into
material sugar you're taking matter that
already exists in the form of
six molecules of carbon dioxide six
molecules of liquid water and using the
energy of the sun to power a reaction
that combines them into a new substance
with molecular oxygen as a byproduct
think of it this way when you bake a
cake you don't say that you made cake
from heat it would be more accurate to
say that you took flour
eggs sugar and butter
and used heat to combine them into
something new
so sticking with our analogy the
ingredients for photosynthesis are just
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere and
water from the ground
with light to do the heavy lifting
carbon dioxide
and water
are put together to produce a
carbohydrate which literally means
watered carbon
as you can see with this typical
carbohydrate molecule
glucose
your carbon is attached to the same
atoms that compose water to hydrogens
and oxygen
this carbohydrate has more chemical
energy or bond energy than the molecules
of water or carbon dioxide that served
as ingredients
thus the energy at the end of the
process is much greater than the energy
that the ingredients had at the outset
this means that photosynthesis is a sort
of useful reaction that stores energy
like a big biochemical solar cell
we call these endergonic reactions
and you might be able to see already why
they would be so valuable in biological
systems you take molecules that don't
have much energy and use them to produce
something that can do work and the
kitchen where all this work happens is
the chloroplast literally the green
maker the chloroplast is a little organ
or organelle present in some plant cells
and it's what makes plant cells and
ultimately plants green and this is
because the chloroplasts bear the green
pigment chlorophyll
now the same way that the word
photosynthesis can be broken down neatly
into its two base words the process
itself can be separated into two neat
little segments i like to think of them
as a charging step where energy from
light is converted into chemical energy
and a synthesis step where that energy
is used to do the work of actually
synthesizing the end product typically a
carbohydrate
so the first segment requires the direct
input of light and as such is referred
to as the light dependent reactions
these happen in a section of the
chloroplast called the thylakoid they
form these neat little pouches the
inside of which is called the lumen in
the outside called the stroma when a
photon of light ends its eight minute
journey from the surface of the sun to
the surface of a leaf its energy is
absorbed by the chlorophyll embedded in
the thylakoid membrane
this energy powers a pump which
literally charges the inside of the
thylakoid like a battery by moving the
ions inside
as the charge builds up the energy can
be used to do work
but the next segment of this process
happens outside of the thylakoid in the
stroma
so to get that energy where it's needed
the thylakoid transfers the energy to a
molecule called adp adenosine
diphosphate by adding another phosphate
bond and making it atp adenosine
triphosphate
now you might have heard of this one
it's often called the energy currency of
the cell pretty much wherever energy is
needed for a cell to do work atp is
involved you might have also heard that
the energy is stored inside of the
phosphate bonds
and that breaking them releases the
energy
but try to remember that these bonds
depicted by the lines in these diagrams
are just a convention it represents an
adherence of these atoms together via
attraction and it shows you where they
adhere but the energy isn't actually in
the
bond the attraction between the atoms
builds up potential energy like a rubber
band that's being pulled really tightly
when you let it go it could hit a paper
cup and do the work of displacing that
cup the rubber band then falls to the
ground in a low energy state because its
energy has been released
so when you put the energy into a system
great enough to overcome the attraction
between the atoms and force them apart
thereby breaking the bonds atoms or in
this case a whole phosphate group can go
spiraling off taking what was potential
energy with it if it hits something that
it can bond with that energy is released
as the bond is formed and can be used to
do work
such as the magic of atp it's described
as energetic because it's easy to break
the bond between it and the last
phosphate group meaning you don't have
to put much energy in
but you get a ton of energy out
so back to the thylakoid those photons
of light were able to net us a highly
energetic atp molecule but the next
segment of photosynthesis is going to
need some electrons too that light
energy is used to do the work of loading
up a mobile electron carrier with
electrons and a proton
this carrier is called nadp plus and
when it's got a full load to take to the
next set of reactions it's called nadph
and that's pretty much the light
dependent reactions in a nutshell the
only other thing you should probably
remember
is that well this is where all the
oxygen in your lungs comes from so you
know no big deal no big deal when
chlorophyll gets excited by that photon
of light
it turns into a real bully the work it's
doing creates such a powerful
electrochemical imbalance and the
chlorophyll balances the equation by
just stealing an electron from water
this causes water to fall apart
releasing its oxygen which the plant
just lets go of
so now that we've taken care of the
section that's dependent on light let's
discuss the section that isn't
the light independent reactions or the
calvin cycle occur in the stroma of the
chloroplast and this is where the
earth-shattering chemical reaction
occurs that allows for all life on this
planet the fixation of gaseous carbon or
inorganic carbon into carbon chains
organic carbon
and this is so important because
fixation doesn't just happen on its own
co2 in the atmosphere doesn't form
organic chains or sugars when it bumps
into more co2 in the atmosphere it
requires the help of enzymes and
energetic molecules made by living
organisms it's why when we first landed
a rover on mars we immediately started
looking for the evidence of organic
molecules it would be evidence that
something is or was living there in the
light independent reactions a plant
enzyme fixes carbon dioxide from the air
into a chain of carbon
so atp and nadph which were produced in
the light dependent reactions provide
the energy and the electrons to create
two energetic reactive molecules that
can be combined to make glucose or other
useful molecules
and the beauty of it is that the
byproducts of the light independent
reactions adp and nadp plus are shuttled
off from the stroma back to the
thylakoid for more light dependent
reactions where they can be recharged
and recycled for use again later
and voila
photosynthesis
the takeaway here is that photosynthesis
allows you to go from the intangible
energy of the sun to the stored chemical
energy that life on this planet is based
on
the sun's energy is converted to the
chemical energy of a carbohydrate
molecule in the chloroplast that
molecule can later be broken down and
most of that energy reclaimed either by
the plant or by creatures that eat that
plant
all life on earth is carbon-based and
every single molecule of that carbon
once existed in the atmosphere in
gaseous form as carbon dioxide until
some enterprising plant or microorganism
synthesized it into something you can
use and while they were at it many of
them filled the atmosphere with the
oxygen that we all need to breathe
so the next time you see a plant
shake its leaf and say thank you